nommé rabibochage qu'on aimerait faire
ce soir c est ce qu une réconciliation
entre orchies de favori gilles favard et
gilles verdez est possible ap contexte
du clash gilles favard était l'invité de
tp pour évoquer la prolongation qu'il ya
même un peu léger ça a très vite
dégénéré se connaissaient déjà depuis un
moment mais n'ont pas résisté à régler
leurs comptes sur le plateau ils ont
tout mélangé le pro le perso l'argent
l'amour à fatou passeur bref regardez
les images
il faut de gt gt du thon de baisse et
c'était avait dénoncé où il m'avait même
dénoncé mois
concernant péché de travail et il m'a
mis sur des listes noires il a été
violent avec des amis à moi des
collègues il les a longuement bousculer
c'est que j'ai jamais rempli à cvg mille
lettres de motivation on est toujours
même si jamais boisset
[Musique]
gilles hervet tu vas tu t'énerves et toi
t'as pas buter taillé dans un
casse-croûte de bal musette
vois ça fait cinquante ans que je suis
dans le milieu du foot ça fait sens bien
c'est à dire du monde des films doublés
j'adore ce qu'il fait mais il est là une
fois tous les six mois les débats il a
dribblé à chaque fois qu'il n'en vaut
plus idéale en bois jeux la danse mais
bon alors gilles verdez et gilles favard
jill
qu'est ce qui se passe avec gilles on en
est ou parce que c'est vrai que c'était
est-ce que je peux commencer oui parce
que vous êtes le rabibochage donc si
vous êtes là gilles favard et je vous en
remercie c'est sans doute pour vous
excuser
bien entendu j'accepte rêve aux excuses
si elle c'est
parce que vous m'avez quand même meurtri
considérablement vous m'avez
devrait être accusée d'avoir produit de
fausses notes de frais ce qui est un
délit monsieur fabas et n'ai jamais fait
ça n'est jamais dit donnez nous votre cv
il est totalement faux ça va chose est
vrai chez vous fera vivre avec brive et
sa vraie paix au karabagh
vos excuses je les attends de pied ferme
alors écoute moi si tu veux pas qu'on
parle de choses qui vont déranger des
gens je vais te parler d'un certain
mariage à cuba de ta part en août a
laissé des gens en plans ou des rentrées
en laissant des quelqu'un avec qui tu
t'es marié à cuba dans puisque tu as
voulu rentrer dans ces cas là tu as bien
fait de l'ouvrir était malade
laisse le kenya et les jours mais il et
il est parti tu l'as dans les années 80
il y
avait des petits arrangements de
rassurer j sais quoi de ma fille c'est
la mère de ma fille et la laisser la
muraille à cuba mais tu brûles la mère
de sa fille donc tu vas fermer ta gueule
même si c'est la dernière mais là à
l'air d'un vieux pneus crevés
tu vas te taire
logique non mais j'y peux pas dire ça là
là ils attaquent sur le perso abaissé la
note
c'est la maman de ma fille non seulement
je me suis marié à cuba évident mais il
s'est rien passé
le majeur a été légalisé mais je m'en
prends vous jouez cpc mais vous êtes
malade vous le mariage a été légalisé
qu'est-ce que mais qu'est ce que t'as
diane
j décrété en touriste à cuba touristes à
cuba gêné pour marier mais t'es malade
vous êtes de mcgill les landes était
revenue avec une femme mais oui ma faute
avait mis les malades que tu as un petit
peut-être un petit peu on va te dire
certaines choses étaient que tu as
laissé que ta plante et coulé parce que
tu es un planteur tu sais ce que c est
implantée là c'est là mais je vais
là-bas je vais
vivre
[Applaudissements]
mais la main s'était vu sur un terrain
je pensais que ça allait être calme
c'est que sincèrement je sais pas ça
s'appelle le rat biboche mais je vois
que tu dis
dans mes choix de teintes arrêt complet
mais c'est pour ça que tu fais ça
lembeye son tintin mais les maladies
dont il a toujours un taré la dernière
fois qu avait fait illusion parce que
guillaume genton avait donné trois
répliques sinon tu as été complètement
transparent et je suis au courant
pourquoi on appelle le spectre
santos écoute moi mais vous avez vu ce
qu'ils disent est réelle
[Rires]
mais s'il retire ce que tu as dit sûr je
suis bon à rien du tout aisée les russes
maintenant tu veux mais j'accepte
j'accepte accepte rien du tout et
maintenant tu me les brise ok je t'ai
dit la dame sans fils et va rentrer dans
la loi de l'emmerdement maximum et tu
veux y rentrer et tu vas y allait
connaître de directoire moi tu vas y
aller et d'ipad et je te regarde à
couper en rondelles toujours promptes et
saucisson mais bien fait et on va te
manger avec des eaux libres
tu as un rigolo ecoute-moi ernest jamais
adressé la parole l'allemand 40 ans je
n'avais jamais vu je pense que
c'est toi qui dis
moi les journalistes incompétents qui
ont fait des frais ça s'appelle leur
wii la psp il a fait le parisien
l'équipe et le parisien chaque fois il
s'est fait virer parce qu'il faisait des
fausses notes de frais parce que c'est
son fils à l'abri au nez c'est le maire
propose que vous vous redescendez
redescendre les corps il est indécent
mais par des sangles tunique je vais pas
redescendre on va essayer déjà de
rabibocher matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
là
ajilon les maux comparables
c'est matthieu delormeau famille on va
essayer en attente
et moi c'est votre bail battures de lobo
fabrice di vizio c'est vrai qu'ils se
sont souvent cachés sur le plateau
regardé et on espère que ça
que vous avez et en particulier matthieu
delormeau le problème qu'il a c'est
qu'en fait ils donnent un avis dont on
ne se tape il raconte n'importe quoi
régler je m'en fous mathieu et les
personnes ce domaine
ces personnes à très hauts salaires qui
la joie c'est ça ton problème mais là
c'est pour toi tout est chaud tu es un
mec moi le deschaux le comics la télé
réalité pour toi mais c'est pas ce que
je vais dire ma cg de dire ce que tu m
as que je vais te le dire un bobo et les
nouilles et non des pays comme le vaccin
fils centre à ce qu'on l'entende
étudiants volumen son père perturbe en
rien du tout quoi ou la tête tous les
cas c'est bon
en fait c'est en fait c'est une manie
dès qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec toi tu
quittes le plateau était en 4e division
2 mais
j'étais pas dans la merde
je savais pas que j'étais fâché avec
mathieu
on n'est pas fâchés avec matthew alors
vous êtes rabibocher tout de suite
absolument
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à l'école il mais provient des jeunes et
qu'il ait jamais honoré sa se soient
payés oui mais c'était à une invitée
pardon dans l'aube et fabrice ont fait
des petits soucis pareil parce que tu es
venu dans tpm p ouais c'est vrai
pourquoi ouais en fait il ya deux choses
alors tpm fait savoir à quand tu es mon
domaine
mais deux tu sais que mon cabinet je
vais peut-être d'un gros cabinets ne
peut plus rien publié dans la presse par
la presse médicale ou ailleurs à ce
qu'on me dit que je suis black-listé
parce qu'effectivement je suis venu
sûreté pmp et que c'est vulgaire que je
suis moi même vulgaire alors j'aime
beaucoup ce mot de vulgaires parce que
je pense que ce qu'il n'en prennent pas
ce que ça veut dire baisser un bus moi
moi c'est ce que j'aime en fait il se
rapprocha je m'intéresse parce que en
fait ce que j'aime dans cette émission
c'est que elle est vraiment cessé
stendhal tu verras tout à l'heure c'est
stendhal qui écrivait
il n'y a rien de convenants que le 19e
siècle stendhal en fait ils
connaissaient pas de vingt-et-une rôles
et ce que j'ai lu dans cette émission
c'est qu'elle est venue lorsque deux
jeunes dans cette émission c'est qu'on
peut se dire les choses voilà exaucé
c'est le principe en fait de la société
où il faut arrêter à un moment donné
quand on doit dire merde à quelqu'un on
lui dit mr des femmes bien sûr et à
raison voilà c'est ça et ça veut pas
dire qu'on ne savait pas dire pas de
respect pour lui moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui sont ici mais
mais de grâce continue à être ce que
vous êtes continuons-nous clash of
america et quand ça me bouffe leur âge
partir f1 de l'histoire fabrice moi je
suis moi je dois dire je suis très
heureux de t'avoir connu bah moi aussi
mais gagne encore vivant
[Rires]
et que tu vois et que ce soit avec nous
très souvent et j'espère qu'il reviendra
nous voir aussi souvent l'année
prochaine parce que l'on aime bien quand
tu es là moi j'ai trois cadeaux alors
pourquoi j'en ai pour ma tuer j'en ai
pour géraldine mais non mais non ah
ouais un masque
viviani de bâle pully carrière daniel
non par sa cible à sa patte selon la
nationalité ce qu'elle est un meuble
temps madame aubenas dans rome stendhal
et boma direct il s'arrête c'est que tu
as un bon niveau et ça coûte une toile
danger le prix là a un frère la balle
alors alors moi c'est non sans que j'aie
panier matters et le body ses petits non
mais c'est quoi toi tu sais pas
millimono 103 jours philippe delerm je
vais passer pour un vieux con bon très
bien
avec une dédicace pour lille il n'y a
rien de plus combien n'y a rien de plus
convenant danger rien merci à 0,6 après
ça changeait rien fabrice sont allés
rien selon m et c'est un très beau
cadeau que tu m'as fait je te jure mais
vraiment et dédicacé en plus yeux et moi
je donne tu as absolument adorable et
moi aussi ouais ça je pense que je vais
tâcher franchement tu remercieras ton
pote
qui m'a fait la dédicace
[Rires]
au ton pote pas mal qui m'a fait des
dégâts sont jacques connaissait afin
d'appuyer merci
ça va mal parti trop tôt
ému par
les régimes une mention spéciale
vraiment ne changeait rien à battre bien
le seul à dire
change quand même deux trois trucs
démission démission bon bah alors
c'était quoi c'est très beau c'est un
livre illustré par martine delerm les
textes sont de philippe delerm ça doit
être bien et c'est un très très beau
livre ou très belles éditions du seuil
joël a dit le gardien serbe avoue t elle
là bas
je suis
efficace je suis un peu folle non on le
dit transit tout habillé ravi la
différence rafraîchie je me sens si
vivante ne changeait rien merci pour ce
que vous êtes maître division
c'est
après sa mort d'awk fabius moi j'ai mis
à l'abri chez mathieu prenez-vous non à
l'effet de serre a dit
[Applaudissements]
avec les gilles mais c'est une jolie
encourait je vais quand même à moins 6
mois chez moi fabrique c'est une très
très belle rencontre ado c'est la classe
fabrice il a la classe
exact ni l'italien et fabrice on va leur
donner les dates de mykonos
j'aimerais vraiment un peu gillet gilles
ce que gilles favard
c'est vrai qu'ils
voient là où il a feint une entrée trop
ni tonitruante à hawaï a démarré fort
mais il a démarré très fort gilles quand
même à
1,10
des piliers de tpm pays et c'est vrai
que voir deux personnes qu'on aime bien
se déchirer comme ça ça nous fait de la
presse ça fait de la peine toute
l'équipe auto la table et c'est vrai que
ce qu on aime bien gillon l'énergie on a
bien dit gilles en général la plainte
gils adorent gilles lellouche à doha
c'est vrai j'ai déjà plein de gilles que
j'adore et là devoir de gilles
qui sont voilà au bord de la rupture
ah c'est sûr je reviens si vous avez
cité stendhal il ya un instant pas
brillé milou fric citer un autre auteur
qui narre l'osm aïe
ça fait mal
mais je suivrai
gilles et gilles est ce que vous voulez
vous reparler ouais mais c'est une vraie
bombe à bord bon bah ça et ça peut très
bien sûr il y aura la locution chez vous
ce que vous me permettez pour une fois
de faire le premier pas un grand plaisir
la gym ça allait trop loin parce que là
tu remets en question ma vie personnelle
moment là mais les fêtes ont remis ces
choix du toit rigide jonathan laisse
bien évidemment
mais j'en ai jamais
mais nier ou tard et les gt r gilles la
jeune dame élégante elle est unie pas
moi c'est très décontracté aussi belle
attendue du
tgv vers des styles soul artumas traités
de soûlards mais pour être sous là il
faut plus il faut payer des quotas n'a
jamais payé un ta vie donc tu peux pas
savoir
faire rentrer à des régimes qui sont
complètement stérile mais entre un bon
guen belgique alors maintenant je vais
parler j'étais en train de parents dont
j'étais en mission avec quoi faire va
voir les entourages avait raison j'étais
en train de faire leurs premiers pas sur
11 gt alors c'est clair on est trop
lourd à gérer mais jamais géré amis je
vais me rabibocher avec toi jamais à
baja les états unis j'étais venu
j'allais venir te serrer la main je vais
essayer quand même
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que vous êtes rabibocher
les doses comme je le pense sincèrement
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes ravis
beau chèque et je peux tu revenir la
saison prochaine alors si tu reviens
essaye de bois c'est un peu quand même
j'y vais ce que c'est beau c'est que
vous pouvez passer les poules avec
gilles parce que c'est vrai que voilà ça
ça nous fait de la peine vous avez dit
gervinho personnes à charge ou alors je
suis rentré je suis pas rancunier là que
j'ai de la mémoire d'accord donc ça va
vous seriez pas là vous avez oublié ce
qui s'est passé non je suis pas rancune
je suis pas rancunier j'ai de la mémoire
donc je n'oublie jamais rien mais je
peux ne plus jamais en parler alors qui
a compris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai de la mémoire
[Rires]
c'est
gilles excusez moi jill donc ça veut
dire que vous acceptez le premier pas
mais ne premiers pas
n'ont heureusement que valérie suis
pas oui oui en plus on s'était parlé une
fois j'avais appelé après notre
précédente fabrice où j'avais c'est bien
pour ça que je jouis gpra des prix pour
n'ai jamais dit j'avais dit on peut se
mérite et non pas perso et là vous
m'attaquez sur le personnel donc voilà
et moi j'ai face et gfa c'est une
bataille que le parent effacèrent faut
on va pas s'en tirent un trait
[Applaudissements]